during this Black History Month students
around the nation for learning about
icons of the civil rights movement but
beyond those lessons as CBS news analyst
analysis rather found some major
problems in the way that students are
being taught about some very important
moments in American history our national
correspondent Jericka Duncan has been
looking into this and so dareka we've
been promoting your story all morning
long I'm very curious to find out what
you all found out we learned a lot and
what we found out is that how you learn
about topics like slavery and the civil
rights movement really depends on where
you live and the textbooks you're using
and some of the textbooks we looked at
there's information that may surprise
you is there a problem with how we teach
American history in this country yes
renowned scholar dr. Abrams Ken D can't
believe what students are learning about
America's past reviewing these texts
closely you know now I can see why so
many students get to college and and
they're like why didn't we learn this in
high school
because it isn't in these decks we asked
Ken D a CBS News contributor to take a
look at four textbooks used in public
school classrooms the first book the
American Pageant is used to teach
Advanced Placement history the publisher
of the book says more than 5 million
students learn from it each year we
looked at the 16th edition of the book
published in 2016 so here on page 346 it
says in the deeper South many free
blacks were mulattos the term mulatto is
a racist slur against viral people the
book also includes this map referring to
enslaved Africans in 1775 as immigrants
alongside the Dutch the Scottish and the
German to refer to them again as
immigrants insinuates that they chose to
come the African people who almost
totally were forced to come and
certainly did not want to come to United
States and chains just to see if things
have changed we looked at the latest
edition of the book published this year
the map is still there the assignment
asks students to put a price on slaves
what and how students learn about
history is different everywhere and
sometimes problematic
teacher who is white told them to write
funny captions on images of freed slaves
there are reports the teacher made black
students act as slaves there is no
national standard for what history is
taught each state set standards which
outlines what students are expected to
learn CBS News took a look at the social
study standards for all 50 states and
the District of Columbia we found seven
states do not directly mention slavery
and eight do not mention the civil
rights movement only two states
mentioned white supremacy and 16 list
states rights as a cause of the Civil
War which candy says is a problem this
was the term that the Confederate states
that later segregationist and even some
slaveholders utilized to hide that they
were really fighting for the right to
slaveholders Kevin Ellis is the chair of
the Texas State Board of Education about
10 percent of the nation's students
attended Texas public school in 2018 the
state changed its standards to teach
slavery as the central cause of the
Civil War but it still mentions states
rights should states rights even be
taught at all so I think even when you
look at states rights it focused around
slavery and so what we what we're doing
now is just being clear that those
states rights that the South was
fighting over was states rights for them
to have slavery
Kandee also took a look at this textbook
Texas history which is adopted by the
state to teach middle school social
studies it covers topics including
slavery and a civil war this is a
picture and the caption says some US
settlers brought slaves to Texas to help
work the fields and do chores and you
know I don't think we should describe
slave laborers tours a few pages later
candy pointed out this image the caption
for this picture says what
characteristics of slave life does this
image show does this depict slavery if
we were going to have a single picture
that depicted slavery it should be a
picture
that demonstrates terror and violence we
also asked Ellis what he thought about
the picture well I think one of the you
know as we go through the the struggles
and the injustice is that the slaves
went through I think the important thing
is not to do what was done in earlier
times and and make it sound like they
were better off here than they were back
in there this picture this picture
doesn't look so bad you know there's no
marks on anyone's body and this is
supposed to represent enslaved people I
think the point that's being made is the
fact this was not a true representation
of what slaves went there Indian
justices that they went through and and
I can't answer why that made it in that
textbook we have progressed in in the
past five years and ten years and 20
years and we still have more work to do
and I think this would be an example of
that the publisher of that Texas history
book houghton mifflin harcourt told CBS
News in a statement that it appreciates
in values dr. Kennedy's analysis of the
textbook and they are making intentional
changes to the content and future
editions sin gage the publisher of the
American Pageant said the author's work
strenuously to provide an accurate fair
an engrossing account of American
history and they are always striving to
improve they note the newest addition
makes corrections and includes
first-hand accounts from
african-americans of the time so
important to point out though that the
publishers can make these changes but
it's up to the states to adopt them and
you know it's funny because I talked to
a girl friend of mine her daughters in
high school she just got an A in her US
history class and I had told her about
this story and she said we have to teach
them it's up to the parents and I think
there is sort of this unsaid thing even
especially in black communities that
you're going to learn it from your
family and not necessarily rely on the
school to do it just because you look at
these changes that they've made this is
in the last five years it's the most
alarming thing you said that start was
that there were seven states where
slavery is not even meant for civil
rights that's what I find so
jaw-dropping and I think when you're a
kid you're reading the textbook it
doesn't occur to you to challenge it
right I need a story like this to let
you know yes and it's also unfortunate
and I think many times in the black
community not really knowing our history
I think that is a problem
well those girls aren't teaching it
sometimes it's hard to know if it's it's
very very difficult right Rica that was
very informative thank you